he's one of csgo's hottest up-and-coming
in-game leaders
he led an unlikely group of finns to the
finals of a major
beating some of the world's greatest
teams along the way ally chipped in for
a third
out of four and took on it they pulled
off the upset
five months later he was cut from that
same team forced to play the berlin
major with a roster that didn't want him
for months we speculated where he would
end up but now that speculation is
over because he has a new home alexi b
is back they pulled off the upset
to understand why the counter-strike
community is freaking out over lexi b
right now we have to rewind a few months
to when he was playing on
ends historically ents was never a
powerhouse team
the finnish squad bombed out at event
after event
that is until 2019 assembling a new
roster of young talent to play alongside
veteran
allu this end squad shocked the world
with their surprising run at iem
katowice is gonna deny
the finns the kings
they made it all the way to the finals
of their first major beating juggernauts
like team liquid and na'vi along the way
and the team's igl alexi b was a huge
part of that miracle run
and how did you lead your team to mount
that comeback that was insane
we had like eight rounds i just told the
team that we're gonna play default every
round from now on
and we just didn't every round we had a
good flow
everybody had their moments at the major
alexi b
became the face of ants grabbing viewers
attention with his game-winning calls
crazy pop-offs and endearing interviews
on three consecutive maps though you let
them get away with that
yeah but we still won you still won
despite falling to astralis in the
finals ants grabbed new fans with their
surprising major run
[Music]
but it wasn't long before those fans
turned their backs on the org
just five months later ants announced
that they were benching alexi b
after the berlin major yeah they've
having a rough time we'll see how they
go they should do a lot of prep
and then we hear oh sonny's joining
they're in game leader alexey b's out
of course that doesn't seem like a
positive thing it isn't a positive thing
but they've spun it that way out of
all of the players to bench nobody
thought alexi b was on the chopping
block
but there he was i've seen you know lexi
be sitting in the lobby on his own
right i don't know what the rest of the
team's doing but if it is a work
environment that's fine
he's a kid he's 22 years of age if you
think being dropped from a team in a
major isn't going to affect him at all
you're trying to tell me a lie that just
isn't true ensa's decision to
bench their igl completely backfired
their recent performances have been
disappointing to say the least
i cannot believe they're coming into a
big tournament like this with four weeks
of full practice
even a week boot camp leading up to this
one as sony said in the interview as
well
and they look so lackluster they need
desperately somebody to take charge of
this team you know and i don't think
aloe is the game leader
they hoped he would be and i think
that's a fair conclusion to make as well
now aside from a top two finish at the
recent asia championship
ents's slump has been validation for
alexi b fans
having cnn's play without alexi v having
seen them play with alexie b
it's night and dare i do think law that
they cut off their nose despite their
face in this sense they should have
found a way to work through it but
ants has still been competing while
alexi b
has been sitting on the sidelines in
october rumors circulated that alexi b
was to join og's first ever cs go team
the back-to-back ti-winning organization
was expanding into cs go
and after a few months of speculation
that rumor finally became reality
it is time to take all of the majors
the seed has been planted the wait is
over
alexi b is returned to the professional
stage
but this is just the beginning for alexi
b og is his chance at redemption
his chance to show ends just what
they're missing out on
this guy is a monster up and coming igl
tonight like i've very rarely ever seen
someone in the igl role
break out as basically not a rookie he's
playing last year but
a semi-rookie basically and be igl in
your team
to like amazing clutch wins composed
under pressure
alexi b made his og debut last week at
cs summit five
and og came out strong at their first
ever event
i think this is the best case scenario
for og right they ran into the hottest
team in the world right now surely
obviously walks not here nada standing
in
but they took him to three maps they've
obviously improved
tremendously since that first day we saw
them which is huge positives
og is a fresh start for players in
desperate need of one
look at guys like nbk and valde these
players need to hit the reset button on
their careers
and og gives them that opportunity alexi
b will get to flex his igl skills once
more
hopefully bringing up the full potential
of his teammates in 2020 it'll be up to
alexi b
to prove that the hype around him was
justified he led one team to the grand
final of a major
let's see if he can do it again thanks
for watching
if you want more content like this hit
the sub button and ring that
notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages
i